[Music]
to launch our partnership with learn
liberty I'm joined by someone who's no
stranger to explaining complex ideas
Randy Barnett is a lawyer and author and
a professor at Georgetown University
where he teaches constitutional law
ready
welcome to the Reuben report great to be
here thanks for having me yeah thanks
for coming on in you're staying at the
very fancy Chateau Marmont
and you made it all the way over here to
where we are by an airport had to fight
the traffic but it's worth it all right
very good well there's so much that I
want to talk to you about because the
things that you study and that you're an
expert in are exactly the things that
I've been talking about on the show for
quite some time so it's nice to have a
an expert with me so first off let's do
constitutional stuff first what's so
great about the US Constitution well
what's great about the US Constitution
is that it is the law that governs those
who govern us it is not the law that
governs us we're not necessarily bound
by the Constitution as individuals but
it is a law that air each and every
person who's an officer of the US
government including state officers take
an oath to support and enforce and obey
that law that governs them so it is a
charter that subjects rulers to the rule
of law assuming they follow it which is
what they're supposed to do right so
they're supposed to follow it I don't
know that they always follow it or I'm
sure they don't always follow how come
when the president takes the oath he
does it on the Bible instead of the
Constitution wouldn't that make more
sense well they're an oath is supposedly
a act of faith it's an act it's a it's
it's asking you to be judged by God and
God holds you to your oath so it is it
is what makes the Bible is what makes an
oath morally significant to many people
all people in this country have always
been offered the alternative of
affirming rather than taking an oath so
anybody who wants to affirm rather than
take an oath is free to do so
right but everything being equal I
suspect you'd rather have someone put
their hand on the Constitution when
they're yes that ultimately is the right
that's what they're that they are making
an oath to follow and and
and they should follow it and actually
what that means is that they're not
allowed to change it if that's if the if
the Constitution is the law that governs
those who govern us and they can no more
change the law that governs them by
themselves then we can change the laws
that govern us without going through the
legislative process so for example we
can't change the speed limits that
govern us we there's no living speed
limit that we can adjust depending on
circumstances and they should not be
able to change the rules that govern
them without going through the amendment
process but that's not of course the way
they play the game yeah so we'll get
into how they play the game in a little
bit is there one particular part of the
Constitution that you think really like
just nails it perfectly is there
something that you really see is just
the the underpinning of everything else
well I'm known for having a strong
affinity for the ninth amendment to the
Constitution which says the enumeration
in the constitution of certain rights
shall not be construed to deny or
disparage others retained by the people
that is an expressed affirmation of the
retained rights or the natural rights of
the people that first come rights and
then comes government it's an express
affirmation of that and then the 14th
amendment repeats something like that
word says no State shall make or enforce
any law which shall abridge the
privileges or immunities of citizens of
the United States so that applies then
the constitution of state officers in a
way that it wasn't applied before and
that includes both the natural rights
that the 9th amendment refers to and
also affirmative rights that are in the
bill of rights as well so those are my
two favorite parts of the Constitution
yeah so both of those parts they really
deal with the individual right I mean it
really comes down to the individual
person and that the state should not
infringe on your individual rights to do
what you see fit within the laws yes so
when I say first come rights and then
comes government I do mean first come
the rights of individuals the
Declaration of Independence which was
the founding document of the country
then we had two tries a government let
be to make a country the declaration
declares the country we are it says that
all persons are all persons are endowed
with certain inalienable rights among
which are the life rights to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
each one of those is individual rights
life liberty and pursuit of happiness
and the next sentence of the Declaration
says to secure these rights governments
are instituted among men deriving their
just powers from the consent of the
governed so it tells you first-come
rights of individuals then comes
government to secure these rights the
entire philosophy of the country and the
end the Constitution are summed up in
those two sentences of the Declaration
yeah so our founding fathers really were
individualist at heart right I mean when
they were framing this entire thing when
they wrote the Declaration of
Independence and then when the
Constitution came there their whole
concept was that if we can take care of
the individual first that the rest that
the government will have to behave in a
way that will always respect that yes
first come individuals first come rights
but individuals are not atoms they were
not atomistic individuals neither do I
believe contemporary libertarians are
atomistic individuals the reason why we
have rights and the reason why we need
rights is because we do live in society
with others and rights are the way that
define our to the rights of way we
define our jurisdiction as opposed to
our fellow citizens jurisdiction the way
nations define their jurisdictions so
that one nation doesn't interfere with
the internal affairs of other nations
and we don't get wars
that's what rights are for in society
with others each of us needs our own
jurisdiction to make our choices and
that jurisdiction needs to be defined
relative to other people's welfare as
well so we are individual individuals
but not atomistic individuals right so
let's back up to the Declaration of
Independence for a second because the
line about the pursuit of happiness
there's some comic that I heard do a
funny bit I can't remember who it was
though that line that we're the only
country that has something like that
that you're here to pursue your own
happiness that puts a lot of pressure on
us that we're supposed to pursue
happiness where a lot of other
governments they're not they don't
really exist to have us pursue happiness
they give it you know it's to pursue the
government's means or to make more
product or something like that so that
really is a unique line that our
forefathers put in there that really has
helped spread freedom right well it's
the ultimate end
I mean rights themselves are not ends in
themselves rights are the means
to the pursuit of happiness while living
in society with others so libertarians
and classical liberals generally though
we believe in individual rights do not
believe that rights are the end of
everything rights are simply a means by
which individuals are able to pursue
happiness without unduly interfering
with the ability of other individuals to
pursue happiness as well and that
formulation by Jefferson was not unique
to him George Mason several weeks before
the Declaration was written George Mason
wrote the Declaration the Virginia
Declaration of Rights and he also put
happiness and safety as the ultimate end
the pursuit of happiness and safety is
the ultimate ends of society yeah when
you think about the people that wrote
these documents and then you look at our
political systems
we'll get into them later so let's not
go too deep on on what's going on today
don't depress it's a beautiful sunny day
Chateau Marmont and now you're gonna try
to bring me down but it won't bring me
down Dave ah well all right so let's for
now I'll bring you down in about 20
minutes okay but for now let's focus on
just those specific people the founding
fathers really I mean do you consider
them were that they were modern-day
geniuses really or did it was it just a
function of they were escaping a
monarchy basically trying to create a
system and that it it was sort of thrust
upon them or maybe there isn't one
answer it depends on each particular
person ah I mean I really don't know the
answer to this I don't think I've ever
been asked this question before but I
would say they are better educated than
we were than we are that I don't think
they were geniuses I don't think there's
natively smarter than we are
I just think they have a much better
educator education in both their primary
education and in college they learned
they read all the classical writers and
they just knew more facts and they knew
more theory than we know today than most
people today you know we watch our TV
and we we watch reality TV we watch uh
you know we watch the wonderful dramas
that are on TV I don't want to knock TV
I'm actually big onto you I'm a big TV
guy yeah always a lot of good stuff on
now nobody and nobody know I became a
lawyer because of the defense
which was a television show that came
out in the 60s so I'm totally big on TV
but the truth is we're not as
well-educated I certainly didn't get
learn learn in high school what I could
have learned and I didn't even learn in
college what I might have learned they
knew more than we know that's they
weren't better people than we are by any
means but they were they knew more than
we know yeah this is a total sidebar but
I'm curious if you watch Boston Legal by
any change I tend not to watch any legal
shows because I think they're stupid and
and so I mean they don't use to be a
criminal prosecutor gee I'll go so I
know what it feels like to be in the
legal system and none of them ring true
one the only one recently I mean the you
know the wire is famously you know that
rings true by the way about what law
enforcement is like but there's new one
the night of on HBO mm-hmm totally rings
totally true there's a few plot elements
that didn't work that aren't quite right
but by and large that's the way the
criminal justice system and the legal
system feels so you're telling me the
truth of a real trial lawyer is that it
doesn't always get resolved in an hour
is that how it works well I thought it
was always resolved in one day that not
really yeah you're you're right I hate
to break it to you with the commercial
break I hate to break it to you no
actually the reality of the criminal
justice system if you work in it is
better than TV yeah better than until
recently that better than TV could show
you the reality of did an integrity of
how you navigate the criminal justice
system is more interesting actually than
what they depict on television yeah I
mentioned Boston Legal because it was
one of the few legal shows that I watch
and I thought they actually did such a
nice job each week of laying out a lot
of the prints each week they took a
principle and they wrapped it around
some trial that didn't really have much
to do with it but that you got some sort
of message at the end which I thought
was really like that you know and law
and order I'm told I can't bear to watch
these shows but I I'm told that the law
is accurate in fact I have done
consulting for The Good Wife because my
former trial partner in the Cook County
State's Attorney's Office is their
principal legal consultant and I'm told
the Good Wife for example has very
accurate law and I did consult with them
on a couple shows that involve the
Constitution but whether they get the
law right and whether they get the
ambiance of how people act and how
people talk to each other that's two
different things
right and also it's your day job so
sometimes I would imagine you want to
watch some monsters at night or
something else that I still like good
cop shows and stuff but it has to ring
true to me and that stuff just is too
melodramatic people don't give speeches
to each other right
okay so let's back up to something you
mentioned which was classical liberals
and libertarians now I would consider
myself a classical liberal and I've
watched what I think is the sort of
destruction of the left over the last
two years it's been very sad for me and
one of the things I've been talking
about a lot on the show what what is the
difference to you between a classical
liberal and a libertarian well classical
liberal is a larger category and
libertarians are a subset within
classical liberals they're not different
things one is a more narrow subset
libertarians I think the way the
difference is libertarians believe in a
few basic sets of rights of individual
rights and the more radical libertarian
you are the less you think need to be
added to that basic set of rights in
order for society to do well so there's
the right of you know property and
contract and self-defense and
restitution these are the basic rights
that people have and the more radical
libertarian you are the more you think
we can just get by on those rights and
we shouldn't add anything else and then
people think oh well no you need this
and you need that you need this other
thing and then that makes them somewhat
less radical but as long as they believe
that the core of society is the
individual living in society with other
people so there's a society as well as
long as they believe that these
individual rights are the core and that
in some sense first-come rights and then
comes government then that puts you in
the liberal tradition mm-hmm and we call
it the classical liberal tradition to
distinguish it from the term liberal
which got taken over by the progresses
when progressives got a bad name after
World War one
right because progressives they had
their own and they were called
progressives and then they got a really
bad name associated with World War 1
when Woodrow Wilson the famous
progressive is locking up dissenters and
putting and putting Eugene Debs behind
bars who was the socialist candidate for
president got a bad name so they started
calling themselves liberals because that
was a good thing to be called right and
then they gave liberals a bad name so
then we can't call ourselves liberal
because they call themselves liberal
yeah
don't you hate the label part of it
because I find that we to talk about
these things we need these labels and
yet at the same time nobody really wants
to be label then it's usually limiting
because a lot of us have things that
that bleed into the other category well
I went through a phase in which I didn't
call myself a libertarian I called
myself a classical liberal and in fact
the ensue free Maine studies who you
know is sponsoring this or has something
to do with this video yeah
they had that as part of their thing
which was we were liberals who were
classical liberals and I found it
confused people and they would say well
what is that yeah and they would and it
would make it say it would make me
defense it'd make me seem like I'm
defensive like I'm hiding what I am and
I finally realized you know libertarian
actually doesn't have a bad valence
anymore it used to be really weird I'm
old enough to remember when the term was
like really weird I think it still has a
bit of a weird connotation to that to
the masses I mean did you watch I'm sure
you saw it or maybe you attended the
libertarian convention it was it was
quite a show well I saw it on live
stream yeah and I thought it was
actually well conducted I didn't see the
part where the crazy people the guy
would know you know but I think that
whispered on stage yeah I didn't see
that part yeah most of it it was much
more serious and businesslike than the
other convention I had just watched
which was the Republican Democratic
convention so but I don't think it has
the kind of wacky connotation it used to
have in fact why that's so why some
people call themselves libertarians who
aren't because it makes them seem cooler
right so therefore I just embrace it now
so I don't call myself I mean I am a
classical liberal but that's not what I
call myself I just own up to the fact
that libertarian is the best descriptor
of me and I'm good with that yeah how
does a party like the libertarian party
that really is about the individual how
should they because this is like where I
think they haven't been successful is
how do you take people where it's about
the individual and really get them to
unify so when I was watching the
convention for example you know they had
people up there screaming about you know
either legalizing all drugs which I
could be convinced is fine but more
things like you know no driver's
licenses things like that where it's
such a non-starter for so many people
like it just seems so silly like to get
in a car you could kill a lot of people
if you don't have to do it we're doing a
license like that seems
within the libertarian contract I think
you can make an argument for that how do
you think they can untie themselves from
some of the most things that are sort of
out there at this point or do you think
that maybe they don't have to your ask
you you want to talk about like how the
libertarian party should be made better
is that well basically yeah then I heard
them talking about like the driver's
license thing and I was like guys you're
arguing about such petty little things
that you're completely missing what the
bigger argument is well I guess I mean I
I have been I was very I very proudly
voted for libertarian libertarian party
candidate in when they first started a
party I went to the New York Convention
in the 70s the presidential nominating
convention so I really liked the fact
that there was an LP when it got started
but I was quickly I quickly came of the
opinion even into the 80s and the 90s
that it was a big mistake to have a
libertarian party and the reason was and
I got invited to Libertarian Party
conventions to debate people on whether
there should be a libertarian party and
the reason was that I thought first of
all we have a two-party system based on
the voting rules that currently are in
existence and to have a libertarian
party basically a third party will
basically cost the party that's closest
to it votes and help the party that's
farthest from it will drain votes from
the party that's closest to it that's
not a good thing right the second thing
that makes it not a good thing is that
to the extent people want to be
political activists they don't want to
be professors and they don't want to be
writers they want to be political
activists and you instead of saying okay
go out and find the party you feel best
about the Democrats Republicans and make
that party more libertarian it drains
those people into a libertarian ghetto
party that's never going to win and say
and and that by definition makes the two
major parties less libertarian at the
margin because libertarians are invited
out of that party right if there was a
law that said they had to go into the
third party libertarians would resent it
but they segregate themselves so for
these two reasons I was against the
libertarian party now this year of all
years the year in which they mayor not
there may not be a lesser of two evils
there's always a lesser of two evils
right there's no natural law that says
there has to be a lesser of two evils
they might just be bad in their own
equally bad yeah this is the year when a
third party like the Libertarian Party
really Shh their existence for right
don't tell me about they're gonna get
ten percent of the vote this year
because it's gonna help in the future
this is the future the libertarian
party's been around for forty years or
thirty years however long they've been
around this is their year and they and
they don't seem to be up to the
challenge this year of fielding a
candidate that's genuinely attractive
whether Gary Johnson is better than
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton that's
a reasonable conclusion one can reach
because they're so bad but we shouldn't
have to settle for that we should have
actually they if they hadn't been able
to field if they're not able to field a
candidate this year yeah went which
should be their year then they're never
going to be able to really yeah I did a
video a couple weeks ago about why I
wanted to at least support Gary Johnson
until the debates let's at least get one
other voice in the debate I think you
need to be in the debates yeah I you
know that's a Riggs that's another
version of the rigged system for
two-party system the debate the two
parties got together and they created
this debate commission that they won't
you know that that has to that creates a
threshold to let another party into the
debate so to basically screen out other
parties it's working very well for the
two parties it's really it's another
reason but I think Gary Johnson should
definitely be in the debates but I
really think that the Libertarian Party
this was their year to nominate a real
contender to be President and I don't
think they've successfully done that
right so without getting too too far
down the rabbit hole of Gary Johnson I
mean you would argue that as a
libertarian he isn't libertarian enough
basically to draw the people right so
like something with the with the cake
and the the gay marriage thing like he's
for forcing the private business owner
to bake the cake that seems very silly
to me I am okay with a Libertarian Party
candidate who's not purely or perfectly
libertarian first of all almost nobody
is because everybody disagrees about
what it means to be a perfectly very
libertarian exactly so but I'm ok with
them making political compromises you
know I work for Senator Rand Paul he is
a libertarian he may not be perfectly
libertarian in every respect although I
think he's very
Terry and I worked for him on his
presidential campaign and so I like him
yeah I wish he were the candidate I
wanted him to be the king he was the
only one that was different I mean I
guess Trump was different too than the
rest of them but Rand Paul was the only
one with really but libertarians dumped
all over him
while he was running is not being
libertarian enough and he was too
libertarian ish and look who they've got
who they picked right but anyway the
point is is I'm okay with somebody who's
not perfectly libertarian it's just that
in this case Gary Johnson and I don't
want to dump on him because he still is
better than the other two in this case
Gary Johnson has run away from
libertarian positions that would
actually appeal to disaffected
Republican voters but Gary Johnson is
running to his left even where genuinely
libertarian positions like gun rights
for example would help him to the right
he he doesn't that's not where his heart
is that's not where he's running I mean
look he's being who he is fine but
that's this is the year in which you
could actually compete for Republican
voters and he really is drawing more
support from Hillary I think right polls
have shown so in a lot of respects
basically he's to the left but he's
framing that within a couple libertarian
principles yeah like gay marriage in
marijuana and a couple other things I
don't want it I don't know what's in his
heart I don't really know him that well
and so I don't want to characterize what
he really believes and what what he is
but he's running to his left I mean
there are people who are not
libertarians and very critical
libertarians say look you know this
candidacy is revealing libertarians as
being basically leftist mmm-hmm with a
few with a leftist who believe in the
free market or something right so that's
what they are I don't think that is what
libertarians are but I have to say that
Gary Johnson is somewhat playing to
stereotype it interesting that is
interesting so a couple times you've
mentioned the two-party system and sort
of the rigged piece of this thing I
think that people think that it's
somehow in our system maybe even written
in the Constitution that we're only
supposed to have two parties that has
nothing to do with the Constitution
actually parties themselves didn't
originally have anything to do with the
Constitution parties part a term party
was a negative thing democracy was a
negative term at the time of the
founding democracy had the same valence
as demagogue has today hmm
party had the same valence as parties
has today party was a faction your that
founders were against parties they set
up the Electoral College to select
presidents from just people who people
knew it wasn't going to be parties but
it turned into a party system very very
early on so and it maybe it needed to
maybe maybe the founders were wrong
about this and then in fact people need
to organize themselves if they disagree
and organize themselves into groups and
associate and but it doesn't necessarily
have to be a two-party system but there
are things about our voting system it's
basically winner-take-all
first-past-the-post voting which if you
get 51% you get the entire office mm-hmm
you don't get 51% of the office you get
the whole office right that means you
parties need to get to 51% and that
means they basically have to put
coalition's together of voters to get to
51% mm-hmm whereas in a parliamentary
system you can have isolated parties and
then to form a government then you put
them all together
so that it's a different system and that
leads to two parties or it leads to a
few handful of parties but in addition
to that the parties have in fact rigged
the voting rules to in to to to entrench
themselves so for example there's all
kinds of restrictions as to who could
get on a ballot in different places that
privilege the the existing two parties
yeah I heard a lot of the Bernie people
saying during the primaries while the
primaries were rigged and now we know
that the DNC definitely was doing some
things to do that but one of the things
that I saw people were upset about was
that in certain states that they didn't
have open primaries in every in every
state now I would argue you shouldn't
have open primaries because then you
could have people that you know are not
going to vote for the presidential
candidate of that party purposely load
the the ticket there you know load the
voting system in there in the primaries
do you see that as a legitimate problem
the whole primary system is a problem
the whole system we have today it was
basically invented by the left the this
part of the Democratic Party in the wake
of the McGovern situation in in the 70s
and then the Republican Party just took
onboard this primary system that the
Democrats had invented without thinking
about it wait can we pause there for a
sec so what the the Democrats did that
because
basically the party leaders wanted to
make sure that McGovern that there would
be an out pretty much right right I mean
that we know they would pick Hubert
Humphrey whatever whoever it would be
and so the radicals in the Democratic
Party wanted to open up the Democratic
Party so that more progressives could
get nominated in the future and it's
really worked out pretty much for the
left of the Democratic Party the left
has taken over the Democratic Party from
what it was when I was a kid which was a
mix of liberals and leftist and that but
the Republican Party just took on board
the same voting rules in the same open
primary or even the fact that there
would be primaries primaries were not
all not every state had primaries in the
past right the Republicans really need
and actually both parties should but at
least the Republicans need to completely
rethink how they select their president
state-by-state and I know
someone I co-authored with J cost who
works for the Weekly Standard wrote a
piece about how to redo the primary
system I can't give the exact citation I
think it was in the Atlantic or might
have been in the nation maybe was in the
nation and I thought it was made a lot
of sense but Republicans really need to
rethink how they select presidents
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]